the GitHub repo for this project is
shown on the slide here and yeah as I
said it's open source you know
distributed python SQL engine pretty
similar to spark SQL in terms of
functionality right now that I'm doing
as part of my PhD research
so yeah so brief introduction what is
quokka or quokka
um so yeah I believe many people here
are familiar with Presto or Fino or
spark SQL and there are newer
Alternatives like modin or pullers that
all offer you know a data frame API or
task right offer data frame API but a
lot faster than pandas because they can
use multiple cores on the same machine
or maybe multiple machines in a cluster
so yeah quoka is basically that it's yet
another distributed data frame Library
except everything is in Python so this
makes it different from Presto Chino
spark SQL which are all based on the jvm
and stuff so Koga is also thought
tolerant so this makes it different from
Polaris or desk or or Presto or Chino
meaning that it can recover in the
middle of a query if you're using spot
instances and one of them happened to
get unplugged by AWS
so uh Koga supports the data frame API
with pretty strong SQL flavor right now
uh you can do arbitrary filters with SQL
statements etc etc
um
and I guess the most interesting thing
about quokka and why I'm presenting at
the pi data Global conference is
actually just to make a point that how
easy it is to build something like this
with the amazing uh tools that we
already have in the open source python
Community for example quokka is
completely built on top of Open Source
python projects like Ray Apache arrow
and polars I also use redis and the red
is python client
uh to do the coordination so how qualca
works is that there is a array
coordinator that spawns a bunch of right
workers if you guys are not familiar
with Ray I strongly encourage you to
check it out uh Ray and it's uh the
company that formed around at any scale
are really doing a good job uh making it
really easy to do distributed
computation uh and spin up different
workers on the cloud as well as locally
and so the ray coordinator spins up a
bunch of Ray workers which are basically
actors that have some State and County
functions uh and yeah so I use Apache
arrow and polars which I believe there
are also some talks about that part
about data Global here which is a new uh
really fast you know single machine uh
data frame or SQL Library written by
Richie that has really come out in the
past couple of years is the fastest way
to execute a data frame operations
locally so yeah so quokka uses a polar's
library on single machines as well as
Apache Arrow to shuffle data across
these three workers so now that
basically we have you know single node
rayworker executors that can execute
data frame Expressions really quickly
and we have a coordinator with a redis
global store to con to store some Global
control State about this application we
can chop up you know a data frame
execution plan into many different
pieces dispatch them to these Polaris
workers running locally
um
and yeah you have a distributed uh
python-based data frame system
so
I guess another way to think about what
coca is is maybe distributed pullers
like if you take Polaris locally and you
try to
um make it distributed and use multiple
machines this is what you'd get
so a few notes about forecast
performance I mostly compared it on like
some tpch queries which is industry
standard SQL Benchmark TPC
and using parquet file input starting
from AWS S3 which is called storage that
is really cheap and I compared it to
Chino which is uh which is formerly
known as Presto SQL which uh which is
probably the industry standard way of
running SQL analytics on cloud storage
these days as well as spark SQL which is
also a really popular solution we see
that uh quokka is a bit slower than if
you know but quite a bit faster than
spark SQL for most of these queries and
it's important to note here that Fino
does not support the fault tolerance
semantics that cover and Spark SQL
support which means it cannot recover if
uh one of the machines in your cluster
dies for example if you're using spot
instances or something like that
so yeah so should you use coca today
right as I stated in the beginning of my
talk there are many other Alternatives
today that you can use like spark SQL
and China obviously as well as modern uh
task and maybe even just pullers on a
single machine if your data set size is
not huge I mean first if you're curious
about this uh you should definitely talk
to me and email me at this email address
right here uh happy to discuss quokka as
well as why I built it in the first
place and where I'm taking it next
um there are a few reasons why you might
want to use something like hookah today
so for example if your workflow is like
really UDF heavy is a lot of user
defined functions and
um
but somehow you know spark cannot
support it because of the poor Java
through python interface or something
then you could explore you know
something like poker now if your
workflow is pure SQL you know and like
fault recovery doesn't really matter
there are solutions like trino and star
rocks which is I believe commercialized
now is seller data or something that
will solve your problem a lot better and
if your workflow is like UDF heavy but
you know reliability is very important
and you don't really care about speed
and you want to go with some established
solution then I think you should stay
with spark otherwise you know you have
some workflow that is taking a lot of
time has a lot of udfs maybe you you
could try cocoa
and I'm definitely happy to make it work
for your use case so
you can contact me here
um and yeah so I guess finally I want to
just a couple notes about what I'm gonna
do next so I I mean I built coca as an
intermediate tool to support several use
cases related to recommendation systems
especially uh given I used to work in
finance and other cases where you want
to predict things that will happen next
given historical features so I will be
building some future projects on top of
quokka that have to do with like
terabyte scale time series analytics
such as as of joints window joints range
joins point in time joints all the kind
of joints with time series information
where are Goods
SQL engines don't typically support that
well and also I'll be building some back
testing in the feature pack filling
features on top of quokka so if you
define some feature uh feature
definition based on SQL and you want to
compute with that value of the feature
is at a point in time in the past and
you want to do that across all of
history that is a bit difficult right
now and yeah so I'm gonna try to do that
in Quaker next as well but so in
conclusion coca is this python-based SQL
and data frame Library built on top of
this really amazing
open source python Frameworks and the
core of it is really only just a
thousand two thousand lines of code
compared to the code base for spark SQL
which is I believe 30 000 lines of Java
or something that really goes to show
the strengths of the open source python
ecosystem and it's a big reason why I'm
presenting it at this conference and
happy to you know interact on GitHub or
send me an email if you have any your
questions and yeah thank you